These techniques are wonderful
for raising the students'
energy level, for relaxing them.
They can be done with the entire
class at the beginning of class
which is the best time to do
it or if kids are losing focus
or they're tired, you can, if
you give the kids permission,
they can go off to the side of
the room, take a few minutes
to do any one or a series of
these techniques to get refocused
and re-energized and then
go back to their work.
You take what's called
the athletic ready stance,
where your feet are
comfortably apart,
little wider than shoulders
width, the knees are slightly bent
and the back is straight.
And this technique, you
simply rotated the hips
with the arms flopping
out from the body,
your head turns with your shoulders.
You don't force it though.
But the hips lead.
It isn't the arms leading first
and then the body following.
The hips lead first and then
the arms follow after that.
You allow your head to turn.
Keep the knees bent.
And if you keep this up for-- and
it's easy to do, don't force, two,
three minutes, you really
feel good afterwards.
You feel relaxed and
you feel energized.
This technique works all the muscles
in the body and neurologically,
it programs the kids
to be ready to learn
and then you just allow the
motion to come to a gradual halt.
So the idea is, put the
hands together over the head,
come up on one leg, bend the
knee and you focus on your belly,
actually a spot in the middle of your
abdominal cavity, between your belly
and back and left hip and right hip.
It's just to get balanced
and focused.
Come down after doing
that for about 30 seconds.
Shake it out with your feet.
Go back up on the other leg.
Try not to look at
anyone or anything.
Be in what we call soft
eyes, where everything comes
into your field of vision.
You don't look out on the world.
Okay, you come down and
again shake that out.
The palms pushed together here
in a nice symmetric fashion
and the knees are slightly bent.
The back stays straight.
Push the palms together and inhale
through the nose as you go up.
Once at the top, turn the palms out,
exhale through the mouth
[breathing], arms extended but uh..
not uh.. tense.
And once they're parallel, bend
the knees again, come together,
inhale [breathing],
exhale [breathing].
And if doing this in a class
setting, you want everybody
in sync doing it together.
One more [breathing], the blades
of the hand are going forward,
the thumbs are going back.
Not the palms forward like
you're waiving goodbye.
Blades go forward, thumbs
go back, biceps, triceps,
trapezious, nice and relaxed.
So you're generating energy, shaking
the hands good but staying relaxed.
And so you do this wrist shake and
a great thing to do with the kids
in class is, you do this
for about ten seconds
and then you call off a
student's name say, Barbara.
And then Barbara waits about ten
seconds after you call her name.
And she says down.
And the whole class then goes [claps]
once, twice, and then come back up.
Do it again.
And you do this with two
other students and finally,
after the third student has done
this, the technique is done.
So we'll just replicate that
again and assume we're calling
on the third student, say Juan.
And we wait about ten seconds and
then Juan will say, down [claps].
And those are the techniques.